at 1 30 in the morning this morning or
last night you know or very early this
morning once again Donald Trump took not
to Twitter where he is now unbanned but
to his own platform truth social truth
essential and once again he started
ranting and raving
the level of instability that these
rants are projecting is really something
else and it seems that with every bad
news cycle the most recent one being
this entire Kanye white nationalist Nick
Fuentes dinner Trump goes more and more
Bonkers on Truth Central there's always
a Feeling
of sort of like what is he going to
become obsessed with next and at 1 30 in
the morning Trump started by re-trothing
his own earlier truth so saying quote
Rhino Carl Rove is a Fox News loser A
pompous fool with bad political
instincts in other words he loses a lot
only good at taking people's money and
wasting it I was 12-0 against him in
Senate endorsements not something I'm
proud of but something people especially
candidates should know
Trump then continuing with another one
of his fixations his endorsement record
also 12-0 in Senate endorsements against
the broken Old Crow Mitch McConnell who
is by the way a six percent approval
rating not exactly great news for the
Republican party now I don't know
exactly what he's talking about there
um you know Mehmet Oz lost it seems
that's at least one in Trump's loss
column it's always very confusing and
he's sort of like the the the Trump will
often limit his endorsement record to
for example like endorsements made on
even days of the month when it was sunny
among that group he's 4-0 for example
you know it's sort of like with baseball
statistics Trump continuing this morning
quote the Manhattan DA's office has not
tried a murder case since 2015 despite
the fact that violent crime in New York
City is at an all-time high remember a
violent crime is higher in Oklahoma City
than it is in New York City Trump
continuing that six years ago and yet
after by the way it's not six years ago
it's almost eight but okay but maybe
math not his strong suit that's six
years ago and yet after years of
Investigation millions of dollars spent
and the costly and laborious inspection
of almost 10 million pages of documents
we are in the second week of a fringe
benefits case over an executive's use of
a company car a company apartment and
his grandchildren's education no such
case has ever been tried before said
this is Trump Furious that his former
CFO
is in legal trouble because of things
that he did quite frankly Trump then
continuing on the crime spree as we
might call it saying quote mothers and
families of victims of violent crime
and by the way mothers is with an
apostrophe it's just crazy mothers and
families of victims of violent crime
which is breaking all capital r records
in New York City are Furious that the
criminals who killed their loved ones
haven't been given a trial in many years
while millions of dollars and years of
work has been spent on a ridiculous
Fringe Benefits case the likes of which
has never been prosecuted before in our
Capital C counties history I think he
means country it is a continuation of
the greatest Capital Witch Hunt of all
time the DA's office should focus on
Capital and murders that's not lowercase
M murders it's capital M and violent
crime not BS and then lastly and as you
might see Trump's grammar and spelling
degenerating the longer this rant
continues quote despite producing tens
of thousands of jobs in such important
and Lasting structures in New York City
it is said that I will never be able to
get a fair trial there now now it's
unclear whether Trump means it is sad
or whether he is saying other people are
saying it's just all so unclear well we
will soon see because this case against
two companies is a disgrace that should
never have been brought and has been
totally disproven even prosecutors quit
the DA's office because they thought it
was unfair now that's a lie prosecutors
quit the DA's office because they
realized we're doing all this work
investigating Trump and he's not going
to be prosecuted they're not going to
indict him and our work is for nothing
that's why they quit one last line from
Trump here such a case has never even
been brought exclamation point before
period
I've never seen grammar like this before
Justice in America
this man is unhinged ladies and
gentlemen I I have not ever seen we've
never seen any president do the things
Donald Trump has done these types of
randomly capitalized
uh misgamored stream of Consciousness
sentence fragments and run on sentences
you see both sentence fragments and run
on sentences
we've never seen anything like this from
any president and the humiliation
continues to grow I think if we want to
find a silver lining here the Silver
Lining is because Trump is posting this
stuff to Troth Central rather than to
Twitter
fewer people are seeing it